kathy wood everyone in crypto knows her
and she came out with some news while
everyone was screaming and saying
bitcoin fell bitcoin bull market is over
it's over it's over it's over watching
the price fall from 69 000 an all-time
high a week ago to under 60 000 this
week traders getting flushed out people
are scared kathy wood came in with the
voice of reason and said no no no no no
hang on a second bitcoin i believe is
still going to go over 500 000. i
believe 560 000 by 2026. she's got a
bunch of models that show all the price
appreciation and stuff like that but her
real thesis is simple kathy wood
believes that all institutional
investors will be required or most of
them at least will be required to put a
portion of their investment portfolio in
bitcoin she thinks up to five percent
most institutional investors will do
these people have billions and trillions
of dollars that are sitting on the
sidelines whether they're invested in
something else or just dry powder
waiting to be allocated to an asset
class and bitcoin she believes will be
that asset class so if we look at the
bitcoin pullback here we we went up we
almost breached 60. we were very close
to 60. we went to 69 000
in bitcoin about a week ago seven to ten
days ago and we've come crashing down
crashing down they're saying now we're
down below 60. uh will's going to tell
us what the mechanics of everything on
chain looks like but ultimately what
kathy's saying is don't be concerned
this isn't this isn't a concern at all
she's allocated a bitcoin a bunch of
other people corporations entities and
countries are also and she's saying this
is not something to be concerned about
and the general way i think about this
is it's a no-brainer right it's a
no-brainer what have we seen over the
last few years the people that were the
early adopters of this whether it was
corporations putting on their balance
sheet whether it was uh billionaires
rich individuals or institutional
investors countries now with el salvador
anyone that has been buying a material
amount of bitcoin for an extended period
of time
and the whole key right and you don't
have to buy billions and billions and
billions of dollars it was just getting
off zero and what we have found and
these people will tell you all the
people that have already done this right
the same people i just mentioned all of
those people will say one thing that one
two three four percent allocation that
they gave the bitcoin has outperformed
everything else it's outperformed
everything else because while bitcoin is
volatile that's true that's true when
they say it is volatile that is true
there is volatility in the market but
volatility can also be your friend
bitcoin has appreciated much more than
any other asset in the market it has
been the best performing asset
essentially every year over the last
decade so what kathy wood is saying is
these institutional investors will do it
for a few different reasons one bitcoin
is a non-correlated asset it gives you
asymmetric returns relative to stocks
bonds currencies commodities et cetera
bitcoin not only outperforms them but
does it on a on a non-correlated
adjusted basis so when you start to
think about what assets these
institutional investors will go look at
bitcoin as a one two three four to five
percent hedge makes a lot of sense right
and traditionally gold has served uh
as this purpose right gold every
institutional investor whether they own
it or not most of them have some small
allocation to gold some ten percent some
five percent some one percent some zero
but most of them have at least something
and i would say that the difference
between bitcoin and gold is we're at a
new age this is the new generation of
gold everyone has says it every rich
billionaire out there every
institutional investor everyone in
financial markets is coming to an
agreement at once that bitcoin is the
new age gold it is digital gold but
better if we listen to mark cuban the
other day everyone likes to give him
crap say he doesn't understand bitcoin
he understands bitcoin very well from a
digital store value perspective he said
it is the best store of value on the
planet and that's why he owns it and
he's correct bitcoin is the best store
value on the planet it's proven that
over the last year while gold has been
down we're seeing record inflation we're
seeing historic levels of inflation your
purchasing power is being reduced at a
historic rate you're literally losing
6.2 percent year over year of purchasing
power and that's just what we know as we
talk about every day some of these
people are telling us on the ground
people who own businesses who own
companies are saying it's 15 it's 20
it's even 25 they can't hire workers
goods are extremely expensive they are
raising prices to do it and you are
losing purchasing power and what has
gold done gold is supposed to serve as
that inflation hedge asset and it has
failed it's failed tremendously it has
failed really bad it is down year over
year it's down one percent year over
year bitcoin is up over 200 250
year over year it has proven it is
knocked out we might as well hold the
funeral for gold gold is done gold is
done not only has the price proven it
that's the ultimate test to me right the
market decides the market came in and
said bitcoin is a better store value it
is a better inflation hedge asset and
the price appreciated because there was
increasing demand for it demand for gold
decreased over time the price went down
but ultimately gold it it's just math
right if you look at gold not only is it
programmatic we don't know how much we
have a general idea of how much gold is
out there we think we know right but the
supply is not really known it's
considered scarce but bitcoin we know
for sure we know exactly how much
bitcoin is being entered into the market
into circulation every single day we
know how much is existing we know how
much is held by certain entities and
wallets we know how much has apparently
been lost forever we know how much has
hasn't moved in 90 days the on-chain
metrics with cash with catch which kathy
mentioned uh has become an important
part of this because you can see exactly
almost in real time what is going on in
the bitcoin network we're going to be
able to see people that come in and buy
billions and billions and billions of
dollars of bitcoin and what they're
going to do is they're going to move
these off exchanges they're going to
purchase them and they're going to store
them and we're going to be able to tell
in real time this is a transparent
market it's unlike anything we have ever
had before we don't know what's what's
happening in the stock market most of
the time hey we have an uh quarterly
earnings report we hear a little bit
about it the stock goes up or down based
on if you hit or miss estimates that's
not cool that's not the way to go
bitcoin is completely transparent not
only in its supply but in its trading
and transaction volume also and i think
what kathy is
saying here is essentially we're going
to see institutional investors opt into
that system they're going to say hey
that's the kind of market we want to be
involved in and i think ultimately what
we're going to find is billions and
billions and billions of dollars are
going to flow into the market and what's
the one thing we talk about all the time
when the supply is constrained and fixed
and we know exactly how it's going to
happen based on software math and it's
programmatic all you have to worry about
is the demand side we know we know for
certain that 90 almost 90 of bitcoins
supply that will ever ever circulate the
21 million bitcoin is currently in
existence currently in existence and
circulating there's 90 of it already
there we know exactly when the last 10
percent will come into circulation we
know it for sure and the thing is with
gold and other assets you don't know
anything nothing is certain monetary
policy could change fiscal policy could
change company earnings could change
asset allocation could change there
could be uh stock buybacks you could
issue more shares you could do all these
things with bitcoin we are certain so
that makes it super simple from a demand
standpoint so all you're really betting
on is this technology going to continue
to adopt are people going to continue to
demand this are people going to join the
bitcoin network are more people going to
buy and purchase bitcoin are more people
going to hold the asset i think for sure
and i think a lot of other people
watching the show would agree with me
that that's for sure going to happen and
if supply is fixed and demand continues
to increase not only from a retail
perspective but we're talking billions
of dollars from institutions now that is
what is going to happen the price is
going to appreciate we're talking about
10x from here a little a little less
than 10x right uh appreciation if we get
to 560.
that's gold that's gold and that's why i
made the comparison to gold earlier
because the gold market cap is 11 12
trillion dollars right now a little over
12 11 11 trillion dollars and if we get
to gold that flip's gonna happen i i i
think that flip's gonna happen and what
we're gonna see is institutions are
gonna stop allocating the gold they're
gonna start allocating to bitcoin and
that's gonna eventually take over i
think what's going to be fascinating to
watch is how much time this takes if we
go to 2026 that's five years from now
that's really not that long right so
there's going to be another halving
cycle and we'll see how the price turns
out but the thing that i think is going
to be fascinating is going to be
watching this play out in real time and
will is going to be key to that right so
will is going to come on in a few
minutes here and will's going to show us
exactly what is happening from an
on-chain analytics perspective why the
price has gone down uh a considerable
amount over the last few days where he
thinks we are in the midst of this bull
market how long he thinks it will
continue what prices he still thinks we
can reach and so on so i think kathy is
right i think we're going to see some
explosion here as more institutional
investors adopt it i think any
institutions that can join in and get in
now is smart it is an asymmetric bet
it's going to return anything
the volatility is your friend in this
situation right we're watching the
government uh see record inflation the
economist had an article out this
morning in our tweet that said no one
saw it coming literally everyone saw it
coming everyone saw inflation coming you
introduced 40 of the money supply of new
money into the economy over the last 12
to 24 months and the economist a
publication that prides itself on
evidence of producing financial uh
evidence and analysis is literally
saying that no one saw it coming hey the
people with laser eyes on twitter saw it
coming they were very loud about it
they've been screaming about it for the
last 12 to 24 months and they told you
that this is what was going to happen
and what we've seen is bitcoin has
reacted to that bitcoin has appreciated
in price and that is the only evidence
you need in my mind is that bitcoin
versus gold has drastically outperformed
in the flash of historic inflation so i
think we're going to see is institutions
are going to continue to adopt us the
people that adopt it sooner than later
will be the biggest winners they will
benefit the most from this and everyone
else will be left on the sidelines and
miss out on record price appreciation
etfs might eventually get a approved
spot etfs i mean and then we'll see
other institutions come to the market as
more vehicles get approved as more
corporations adopt it as more
nation-states make it legal tender as
more billionaires and retail investors
continue to buy it as the asset becomes
more scarce as the circulating supply
continues to dwindle the price has to go
up if demand continues to increase and
supply is fixed we know this we'll see
it play out in real time i think the
next few years are going to be
fascinating but we'll see